[موسيقى]
يؤلمني ان اراه يكبر وهو مازال بهذه
البراءه والطفوليه ربما لانني اخاف عليه
من براءته ونظافه تفكيره وحبه المطلق
للبشر وعدم ادراك الشر الموجود في هذه
الدنيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شفنا نحن بمجتمعنا اوكي من منكرم الام
وبنشوف التعب بس للاسف
ما بنعرف قيمه التعب اللي هم بيتعبوا متل
ما نحن بنتعب هن بيتعبوا على حالهن يعني
ما شي سهل عليهم منه شي سهل عليهم لانه هن
نحنا عم نكسر لهم طبيعتهم
لحتى اذا بدك انا بقول لك اكثر نحن عم
نشوههم عم نشوههم فطرتهم ليصيروا يشبهونا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الشيء الوحيد اللي بخافوا منه هدول انه
يخسروا اهاليهم
ما عندهم اي شيء تقول لك انا اخاف انه
اصحى القى امي ما موجوده اصبح عندهم خوف
لانه احنا اصبحنا الامتداد لامان مش
المجتمع لازم يتغير المجتمع ككل في انه
يشعروا الاولاد بالامان
[موسيقى]